against the backdrop of russia's war in
ukraine nato has agreed the biggest
changes in its defensive posture since
the cold war
we face the most serious security
situation in decades
but we are rising to the challenge with
unity and resolve
members contributions to an enhanced
state of military readiness on nato's
eastern flank were led by the united
states president joe biden said the
alliance had never been stronger or more
united we've reaffirmed that our article
5 commitment is sacred
and an attack on one is an attack on all
and we will defend every inch of nato
territory every inch of nato territory
president biden announced a permanent
army base in poland the first full-time
u.s deployment on nato's eastern fringes
the u.s will also send two additional
squadrons of f-35 jets to the uk
sweden and finland were formally invited
to become members marking the alliance's
most significant expansion in decades
and ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky told alliance members via video
link that he believes russia will target
lithuania next
the summit will have provided the
vulnerable baltic states with a degree
of reassurance
nato is ready
uh to defend
all allies including of course baltic
states and and tilapia
because the
intention of
russia declared
intention is to dominate over europe
over the whole of europe
vladimir putin reacted to nato's
expansion saying if military assets were
moved to finland and sweden russia would
respond in kind
of
it's obvious what don't they understand
that everything was going fine between
us but now there will be tensions there
certainly will
it is obvious and inevitable i repeat if
they represent a threat to us
the only hint of disunity came from
president erdogan who'd lifted his
objections to finland and sweden's
membership bids on tuesday night after a
deal was reached between the three on
measures that could lead to the
extradition of members of kurdish groups
wanted in turkey he warned that if he
didn't see swift action on those
commitments well the membership
ratification process could yet be held
up in the turkish parliament
in his closing comments nato's secretary
general described a world that is more
dangerous and unpredictable and he
warned that things could get worse
a summit that took in climate change
terrorism and the weaponization of space
seldom strayed far from the russian
threat
[Applause]
jonah al jazeera at madrid
efforts to get ukraine's grain out to
world markets to control food inflation
have also taken center stage at the nato
summit our diplomatic editor james bays
has more on that
the un along with turkey have been
working on a plan to try and get the
grain that's trapped inside ukraine out
through the black sea using the turkish
navy to escort the ships and with un
inspectors to make sure those ships are
not carrying weapons when they arrive in
ukraine the plan is also for russian
grain and fertilizer to be brought back
to world markets president erdogan at a
news conference told me plans are
proceeding well
we will continue to conduct found
diplomacy with mr vladimir putin and mr
vladimir zelinski this weekend or
beginning of next week we already have a
road map that has been put in order we
will contact them and try to realize
this grain corridor as soon as possible
an important development in recent hours
the barely populated but strategically
important snake island in the black sea
has changed hands russia says it was
relinquished as a gesture of goodwill
but one ukrainian mp told me it was
actually retaken by his country's forces
when we are saying russia and gesture of
goodwill it's something that couldn't be
together
they just lost the battle for snake
island because yes without snake island
control where we couldn't
provide secure shipments of grain it's
impossible so that was
absolutely needed uh to make these
shipments today we did it the un
believes that the plan to try and get
the grain out of ukraine could be a
major first step in trying to solve the
global food crisis if they do a deal i'm
told it will be signed in istanbul
samir bhuri was a ceasefire monitor in
eastern ukraine and is now a senior
fellow at the international institute
for strategic studies he thinks the
retreat from snake island is an
embarrassment for moscow
ultimately it's an indefensible position
for the russians to hold maybe at the
start of the invasion the russians
thought they might have reached as far
as odessa by now in land in ukraine but
of course they're nowhere near there as
far as kerson so the snake island
territory is not something that they can
defend it's really embarrassing for
russia to have to give this up and i
think the russian defense ministry
statement is really dressing up that
embarrassment but just one other point
on the romania proximity that you
mentioned really really important i mean
this is so close to a nato member state
that one can imagine if there is
actually wind behind the sails of a
ukrainian counter-offensive that snake
island would be would be retaken very
quickly so maybe the russians have
thought ahead on this